want to know what taught in theaters  this weekend today we knew they would be  back and this weekend they invade our  theaters in the epic sci-fi action  adventure film independent state  resurgence they like to get the  landmarks in the thriller film the  shallows Blake Lively stars as a surfer  trapped between a great white shark  feeding ground and safety  and he just lost black-white rich-poor  for something more historical the  action-adventure film free state of  Jones is based on the true events of a  southern farmer who rebelled against the  Confederacy during the Civil War and  finally let's find out what taught in  theaters this weekend with this week's  fantasy patience  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket